[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économique du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui nous sommes au campus de
lisicki à montigny le bretonneux
c'est l'école de l'expertisé numérique
ici 400 étudiants suivent des formations
dans le domaine de la robotique de la
domotique ou encore de la cybersécurité
la cybersécurité il en sera question
aussi dans notre deuxième partie nous
irons à l'école de 1600 de montigny le
bretonneux
ces deux établissements vont participer
le 20 septembre prochain au bik tour
c'est au programme de ce 44e numéro du
sky échos mardi 20 septembre le
vélodrome nationale accueille la
dernière étape du big two rendez vous
autour des entrepreneurs de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de la création
d'entreprise et de l'emploi c'est une
école dédiée à l' expertise numérique
lisier haïti enseigne la robotique la
domotique ou encore la cybersécurité
déformation du bac au niveau ingénieur
elle célèbre sa première année
d'existence situe à montigny le
bretonneux l'école de 1600 est
spécialisée dans la formation en
cybersécurité un établissement qui monte
en puissance
le bic tour c'est le festival des
entrepreneurs et c mardi 20 septembre au
vélodrome nationale un événement
co-organisé par bpi france et saint
quentin en yvelines au programme
découverte des métiers d'avenir des
rencontres avec les différents acteurs
de la création d'entreprise de l'emploi
ou encore de l'innovation mais qui de
mieux pour parler de cet événement que
son fondateur patrick béguin directeur
exécutif de bpi france écoutez le
[Musique]
c'est à la fois le festival tous les
entrepreneurs de l'innovation
mais en même temps de l'emploi en fait
il faut promouvoir l'esprit
entrepreneurial français pour cela il
faut échanger il faut recruter vous
ignorez il faut susciter des vocations
sur les territoires et en particulier
dans les yvelines kiters territoire
extraordinaire des beats
de 11h à 13h nous allons avoir les
missions où vivent ta ville où va mettre
à l'honneur les commerçants les tpe les
pme que nous aurons la chance d'avoir le
miz l'économie des finances sera là la
vice-présidente de la région 1 le mini
jean-noël barrot également puis à 13h
nous allons ouvrir le village le village
de 7000 m² aux 1 avec plein d'expo avec
la découverte des nouveaux métiers de
demain un job dating avec 3000
rendez-vous d'or 13h à 18h30 à 20h nous
allons voir le wattmètre concert
exceptionnel je le précise bien qui va
être avec les haies ladji avec les
chanteurs de beaux gestes et dans son
corps avec les stars les humoristes du
festival de montreux
[Musique]
pour cette étape à saint quentin en
yvelines cher à jean-michel fourgous et
aux sénateurs ogier c'est l'essence même
de la force de cette région et puis
versailles grand parc saint quentin en
yvelines c'est quand même un million
d'habitants derrière toutes les filières
de demain qui s'invente à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'aéronautique
l'avion vers la mobilité l'espère spirit
et l'intelligence artificielle tout y
est on va faire une grande fête ensemble
le festival des entrepreneurs le pic
tour c'est plus que jamais le vingt sept
lors de place to be en france
[Musique]
oh
et maintenant nous sommes avec marqueur
tu as directeur des programmes la 10e'
haïti bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors lisier active apa va participer au
big tour on voit d'ailleurs des machines
que vous allez à mener sur cet évènement
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir découvrir sur
le big tour goûter au bik tour on
voudrait démontrer à tous les visiteurs
que la science et la technologie celle
qu'on enseigne à issy haïti peuvent se
mettre au service des causes très
importante qui nous touchent
actuellement notamment celles qui
tournent autour de l'environnement du
développement durable et de
l'amélioration de la vie quotidienne des
gens et nos élèves chez nous et tu dis
l'intelligence artificielle
les objets connectés on aura un gros
objet connecté une éolienne sur le stand
la robotique on amènera un robot dans
cet esprit là afin de trouver des
solutions qui permettent d'améliorer par
exemple la gestion de l'énergie dans les
bâtiments c'est l'option smart et green
building d'un de nos diplômes à montigny
la robotique et la robotique
intelligente opérationnel et
collaborative avec des déformations de
robotique aussi qu'on va qu'on va
présenter sur le stand du bic tour huit
formations sont proposées ici sur ce
campus à à montigny-le-bretonneux allant
du bts jusqu'au niveau ingénieur alors
on à la domotique on à la robotique on a
le numérique et la cybersécurité
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter ce
campus alors c'est un campus
effectivement pluridisciplinaire
les axes qu'ils développent et dans
lesquels ils développent une forte
expertise sont effectivement la
robotique ou là on a des formations
depuis le bac jusqu'au bac + 5 donc au
début on fait de la robotique de base
est en bac + 5 on atteint des niveaux on
forme des jeunes experts capables donc
de programmer des robots intelligent et
de faire en sorte que dans les
entreprises on puisse faciliter et
transformer le travail des gens et et
qu'on puisse réaliser des tâches qui ne
serait peut-être pas possible de faire
si on avait pas ces robots aussi bien
programmé par par nos étudiants la
domotique je préfère maintenant les
jeunes commencent par faire de la
domotique et c'est un métier captivant
mais nous à nouveau on les monte
jusqu'au niveau bac + 1 jusqu'au niveau
ingénieur dans ce domaine là et à la fin
ils sont experts smart et green building
parce que c'est clairement un domaine la
robotique la domotique qui a beaucoup
évolué et qui s'est beaucoup
digitalisées numérisés et qui intègre
maintenant beaucoup de concept
d'intelligence artificielle
donc ces jeunes là qui sur lesquels on
compte à mon avis pour résoudre des
problématiques liées au changement
climatique et à la nécessité d'améliorer
le comportement énergétique des
habitants d'un building et du building
lui-même oui parce que pour vous
vulgariser un peu le terme domotique il
n'est pas forcément connu du grand
public la domotique finalement c'est la
gestion de l'énergie et de l'atmosphère
dans un habitat ou dans un bâtiment
voilà c'est la gestion de toutes les
fonctions énergétique lumière chauffage
climatisation ascenseur à l'aide de
capteurs d'objets connectés
et de systèmes capables de traiter les
données remontées par ces objets
connectés ces systèmes ce complexe lippi
avant de parler du dernier domaine la
cybersécurité
quels sont les débouchés par rapport à
la robotique et à la domotique pour les
étudiants qui qui font leur formation
ici les débouchés sont
sont très nombreux 1 parce que les
robots ils ne sont plus seulement
présent dans l'industrie donc il est
clair que nos ingénieurs peuvent aller
travailler dans l'industrie là où on
trouve des robots depuis déjà pas mal de
temps mais maintenant ils sont aussi
amenés à réfléchir dans des entreprises
sur des problématiques de robotique dans
les entreprises où on n'avait pas
l'habitude de croiser des robots
en domotique là c'est clair il ya des
débouchés énorme dans toutes les
constructions nouvelles mais aussi dans
tout ce qui va apparaître maintenant en
termes de rénovation de l'habitat et des
bureaux donc là nos étudiants vont
devoir le vrai pour résoudre ces
problématiques qui qui qui sont qui sont
de plus en plus nombreuses et de plus en
plus urgente est l'une de ces
problématiques puisqu'on intègre
maintenant du numérique dans la
robotique et la domotique est bien celle
à ces cyber sécurité parce qu'il faut
sécuriser toute cette numérisation on
l'a vu d'ailleurs dernièrement avec
plusieurs cyberattaques des cyber
attaques qui se multiplient
la cybersécurité est arrivé quand dans
votre établissement alors je me retiens
depuis tout à l'heure de parler de
cybersécurité parce que la cybersécurité
elle est présente depuis longtemps à
l'école dans tous les domaines du
numérique depuis de nombreuses années on
apprend à nos jeunes de développer tous
les projets qu'on leur apprend en leur
disant face et je leur dis toujours sa
cyber by design il faut dès le début du
développement d'un projet que ce soit de
la robotique de la domotique de
l'informatique de gestion pensée
sécurité dès le début dès la conception
du projet maintenant nous avons depuis 4
ou 5 ans monte des formations de
cybersécurité pour former des experts de
cybersécurité et il y en a une très très
couru à montigny sur notre site de
montigné elle est labellisée par l'anssi
ldl délivre un diplôme visé par le
parlent par l'état
c'est assez rare dans dans les rêves
dans les formations de cybersécurité et
là on forme des gens qui vont être
capables de
d'embrasser toutes les problématiques de
cybersécurité qu'elle soit physique
logique peu importe et et ses
problématiques sont présentes maintenant
partout puisque les données elles sont
générées par des objets connectés qu'il
faut sécuriser il faut les transporter
donc il faut un moyen sûr de les
transporter il faut les stocker donc les
stocker de façon sûre aussi il faut les
traiter donc aussi créer des systèmes de
traitement des données qui soient
sécurisés et tout ça dans les deux sens
depuis les objets connectés sur le
terrain dans les bâtiments sur les
chaînes de production jusque dans les
grands centres de stockage de données
merci marc arthas je vous en prie je
rappelle que vous êtes donc directeur
des programmes académiques à lisier
haïti et l'autre sujet qui dont il sera
question durant le big tour c'est la
cybersécurité et il ya une autre école
qui fête ses un an c'est l'école de 1600
à montigny le bretonneux eh bien on va
s'y rendre tout de suite et on se
retrouve devant l'école de 1600 l'école
de cybersécurité de saint quentin en
yvelines elle célèbre ce jeudi 15
septembre son premier anniversaire une
soirée avec des invités de marque et
l'ensemble des étudiants de la dernière
promotion
[Musique]
je m'appelle mathieu je suis
actuellement d'un carence est sold out
avec le patron qui est un bon jour je
suis jean maxime et créateur de sa note
sur note en trois mots c'est un site
internet qui permet d'acheter ou pré
réserver des achats sur un haïku
[Musique]
mois de 1600 j'en ai entendu parler
parce que je fais pas mal de ses terres
donc c'est les compétitions de hacking
et j'ai fait ma licence informatique à
reims est en fait je voulais me
spécialiser dans le cyber on m'a dit de
1600 c'était une école spécialisée là
dedans alors j'ai foncé
et moi c'est simple l'année dernière
j'ai regretté mohamed qui sortait d'un
parcours epitech et qui voulaient se
préciser en cybersécurité il a fait une
super analyse du marché et d'après lui
l'école de 1600 c'est la plus
prometteuse
j'ai rencontré les fondateurs c'est vrai
qu'en termes de programme de ce qu'ils
proposent et même de pédagogie ils sont
super donc cette année j'avais peut-être
deux chez 2006
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yam séraphine je suis directeur général
adjoint d'école 2600
écoles de 1600 c'est une école est
exclusivement dédié à l'enseignement de
la cyber sécurité qui recrutent à partir
de bac + 2 et qui forme jusqu'au niveau
bac +5 et délivre un titre de niveau 7
[Musique]
écoles de 1100 sera présente aux huit
tours sur deux espaces donc un premier
espace on aura un véhicule avec gaël
musqué célèbre hacker éthique qui fait
partie désormais de l'équipe de 1600 qui
va démontrer tous les enjeux de la
sécurité des systèmes embarqués dans un
véhicule la connectivité d'un véhicule
ouvre des potentiels faille pour un
hacker est donc l'objectif c'est aussi
de sensibiliser à cette sécurisation on
aura ensuite un stand où on va vraiment
promouvoir le savoir-faire de nos
étudiants on va avoir de la sécurité web
on va avoir de l'eau zine l'enjeu de la
cybersécurité des crypto
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'il ya une vraie montée en
puissance puisque on a eu l'année
dernière huit cent cinquante
candidatures pour 60 places cette année
on a mille 400 candidatures on en a
sélectionné plus de 110 donc on atteint
on va dire presque deux cents 200
étudiants cette année on a d'ailleurs
aussi été sélectionnés cette année dans
le cadre d'un appel à candidatures lancé
par là sauf toi république la soft
aurait pu qui réunit les groupes renault
et atos thales dassault
stmicroelectronics orange ont
sélectionné écoles de 1600 pour devenir
leur école de cyber sécurité notamment
pour répondre aux enjeux de la cyber
sécurité des systèmes embarqués
[Musique]
et la soirée d'anniversaire 2010 en se
poursuit derrière moi dans le restaurant
juste à côté de l'école et c'est ici que
se conclut ce sky échos merci de l'avoir
suivi vous pouvez revoir cette émission
en replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur tb 78
[Musique]